after Sabine is injured Ahsoka visits
sabine's home to get more information
Ahsoka here is a drawing of lightsabers
and the two women speaking to each other
this power goes by many names in Star
Wars but most probably know it as a
force Echo it's also being called
senseko psychometry and retrocognition
this is a force ability that allows the
users to obtain information about events
or people through a location or object
in this instance Ahsoka is able to hear
what happened drinks have been in Shin's
fight the force Echo has a history in
the Star Wars Legends timeline which
Disney and canonized when it pursued
news stories for film and television
however aspects of Legends have made
their way into new stories and the force
Echo was officially re-established in
Star Wars lore within the hunt for zero
episode of the Clone Wars many will
likely know about the force Echo from
the Jedi Fallen order and Jedi Survivor
video games as well